-Welcome back
and thank you for being here.
Nice to see you. And --
-Nice to see you.
-And thank you for doing the --
the TikTok dance challenge.
Man, oh, man, that's a lot of
pressure.
Do people dance --
-You did good.
-No, I didn't. But --
-I'm proud of you.
-But when people are around you,
like, at a party or wedding,
are -- it's intimidating, right?
Do people even dance,
or do they just leave the room?
[ Laughter ]
-They do your moves.
The one that's like --
-They're just sneaking out.
-Yeah. Sneaking out.
[ Laughter ]
-Congrats on "Te Felicito."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well said.
Well pronounced.
Have a good accent.
-It was good?
-"Te Felicito," perfect.
-"Te Felicito."
Yeah, it came out,
and within a week,
it was the number one song,
so congrats on that.
-Thank you.
-I mean, come on,
how do you do that?
That's got to feel good, right?
-Yeah, I mean, I'm -- Yeah.
You know, I don't put out music
too often, because to me,
it's a priority to dedicate time
to my kids.
But when I do it, I focus.
So -- yeah.
-Yeah, you do it right.
-Yeah, I had to -- I had to
dedicate, like, three months
to just prepare the video.
And --
-I love the video, by the way.
-Yeah.
-Where did the concept
of the video come from?
-Actually, you know,
the creators of the video
are my kids.
-They are?
-They came up with the idea.
-No way.
-Can you believe?
-Yeah, they are pretty creative
kids.
-Yeah.
-They just said, "Hey, what?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know, I didn't have
any idea what to do.
-Yeah.
-When I'm about to produce
a video,
it's like a white canvas.
And -- I have to kind of, like,
sit and think
about what I'm going to do.
-Yeah.
-And I had no idea
what I wanted to do.
So I asked my kids to listen to
the song, close their eyes --
-Yes.
-And listen to the song.
And my little one, Sasha,
came up with the robot idea.
He said, "Mommy, I imagine you
dancing with a robot."
And -- And Milan came up with
the green fire.
And I loved those two ideas.
And I took them to a director.
And that was the whole --
the departure.
-I want to show -- I want to
show a little --
Let me show the clip.
Here's a clip of the music
video, "Te Felicito."
Check it out.
-♪ Con tu papel continúa ♪
♪ Te queda bien ese show ♪
♪ Te felicito, qué bien actúas ♪
♪ De eso no me cabe duda ♪
♪ Con tu papel continúa ♪
♪ Te queda bien ese show ♪
♪ Te felicito, qué bien actúas ♪
-I mean, come on.
Dancing with a robot?
-Yeah, I think kids are
extremely creative, all of them.
-Yeah, they are.
-And as adults, we just have to
take their ideas seriously.
-Yeah, I -- do you think they're
going to grow up
and be in the music business
and be producers or musicians?
-I don't know.
I don't know.
And I want them to do whatever
they feel passionate about.
But I would like for them to
have music in their lives,
because music
gives them so much --
it's a good companion, you know?
In life.
-It really is.
-And it's a good refuge.
It's like -- [ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And --
-It's always there for you.
-And they're learning piano,
they play the drums.
-I heard when you were little,
you almost didn't get
into choir or something.
Is that true?
-That's true. Sadly. Yeah.
-Who wouldn't have Shakira
in their choir?!
[ Light laughter ]
Really?
-My music teacher.
-Wow.
-He didn't like my voice.
He thought I was too disruptive
for the choir,
because my voice
was too strong.
And, yeah, he never let me
in the choir,
and it was a huge frustration
for me.
-Yeah.
-And even my classmates
teased me.
They used to tease me,
and they used to say that
I sounded like a goat.
I hope it was a cute goat.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Now -- now you are the G.O.A.T.,
so there you go.
You did it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Showed them.
-Well, you know, my parents --
-A global music superstar.
-Well, you know,
it was pretty hard
because it was some sort of --
I think it was a way of
bullying, you know?
-Sure.
-Like, I felt bullied in a way.
-Yeah.
-But --
-Did you almost think about not
going forward, not singing?
-Well, thanks to my parents,
I didn't, because my parents
actually reinforced and
reaffirmed my identity
as a singer. And they were --
they said -- especially my dad
always said that I didn't have
to change my vibrato.
I had to protect that vibrato
and never ever change it,
because it was -- he always said
that a voice without vibrato
is not worth it.
It's not a voice, you know?
And so, I kept my vibrato,
and that's kind of my signature.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-Thanks mom and dad.
-My goat signature.
-Your goat signature, yeah.
I know in New York, you were
recently at a Mets game
and cheering on the Mets.
And I was like, "Oh, yeah,
I wonder how you do cheer
at a game," because you get very
excited
when you're cheering for
your sons, for your boys.
I've seen --
-I do.
-I mean, I've seen video.
-I get carried away.
-You are one of those people.
[ Laughter ]
-One of those moms.
-Yeah, you're one --
-Annoying moms.
-Yeah, you just like --
[screams] and you scream.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Can you -- I mean,
do people tell you to, like,
chill out?
-I embarrass my kids.
Actually, yeah, during -- my
little one -- the both of them,
actually, practice taekwondo.
And whenever they participate in
a tournament, taekwondo, they --
I scream like a crazy woman.
And the dojo master, last time,
he gave me two warnings.
The second -- and he said --
-You can't warn Shakira.
No, no, no, no, no.
-Yeah, he almost kicked me out.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Because I was like,
"Kick him in the head!
Kick him in the head!"
You know, I --
[ Laughter ]
-No, she's not kidding.
In fact, we asked you if you
have any video of you.
We have video of you cheering
your son on when Sasha won
first place in karate --
in taekwondo.
Look at this.
-[ Speaking in Spanish ]
[ Shakira screaming
and cheering ]
-Oh, my God, Sasha!
Oh, my God, Sasha!
[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a loving mom
right there.
That is a good mom.
That is -- that's so funny.
Oh, my gosh. You would have
thought that you won.
Oh, my goodness.
That's great.
Let's talk about your new NBC
series, "Dancing With Myself."
-Yes.
-What is the idea behind this --
this show?
-To offer people from all walks
of life and all ages --
A platform where they can
showcase their talents,
but also their passion
for dance.
You know, they don't have to be
virtuosos,
they don't have to be
professionals.
Most of them aren't.
But --
-I like that you're not looking
at me, by the way.
-Exactly. They just have to
dance like you.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-No, They're --
-Yeah.
-The idea with the show is --
is just to offer an opportunity
and access to people from --
yeah, from everywhere, and --
-To dance.
-To dance and to show their
true passion for dance.
You know, like, we had --
for example, we had doctors
on the show, we had
construction workers,
we had people in the military.
We had dentists -- a lot of
dentists, actually.
-Wow.
-For some strange reason.
-It was almost called
"Dancing Dentists" at first.
They changed the title to
"Dancing With Myself."
I know our buddy, Nick Jonas,
is on with you, too.
-Yeah.
-And -- yeah, he's a good --
-He's awesome.
-Yeah, he's the best.
And between the two of you,
I would never want to be
in a dance contest.
I want to --
I want to show a clip.
Here's a look at
"Dancing With Myself."
Check this out.
-Jeremy, can I ask you
what you do for a living?
-Absolutely. So, I am
a plus size model in a --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey!
-You might not be the most
technical dancer,
but I don't care.
Every time I see you dance --
I don't know, it's something
contagious, something infectious
about what you're doing.
[ Laughter ]
And I just want to see more
of you.
Can you show me a model face?
[ Audience oohs ]
-Work. Pose.
Pose, pose.
-No, I smile. [ Laughs ]
-You know, I don't have
a model face,
so I have a mirror face.
I go --
-I've never noticed it.
Not once.
-Work, Queen. Work.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you have a mirror face?
-No.
-Come on, Nick.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey, not the lip bite.
-Yeah, that's how you do it,
right there.
Shakira, everybody!
"Dancing With Myself" premieres
May 31st at 10:00 P.M. on NBC.